début du marathon mi-journée à
aubervilliers en seine-saint-denis
nathalie arthaud quitte le lycée
technique où elle enseigne
l'informatique en gestion
[Musique]
la porte parole de lutte ouvrière à
l'étiquette vu à la télé ces idées
trotsky sont moins connus
je les ai entendus entre eux à les eaux
a expliqué mais oui lutte ouvrière est
les communistes expliquez-nous nathalie
arthaud ce choix de l'enseignement parce
que on sait car dit l'un des fondateurs
de lutte ouvrière recommandé tout
particulièrement aux adhérents le métier
de professeur car il permettait d'avoir
du temps libre pour militer c'est la
raison de votre choix est ce que vous
sentez plus plus militante
qu'enseignante houle inverse au les deux
en fait et c'est vrai que le métier
d'enseignant s'est passé pas depuis hier
des métiers dans cette société pourrie
j'ai envie de dire parce que quand même
c'est aussi un moyen de faire réfléchir
de de permettre à des jeunes d'apprendre
d'être maîtres de leur avenir je
développe voilà c'est une façon de
développer l'esprit critique enfin tout
ça pour moi c'est aussi des choses
importantes voilà
donc bon cc
c'est assez naturellement en fait que je
me suis engagé de ce côté là et puis et
puis c'était voilà je pouvais concilier
justement les deux
[Musique]